no longer is Russia fighting Ukraine but
the whole West nothing that might even
be taken as a sign of dissent is allowed
in Russia right now it's massively early
to say Russia's uh you know a dying
power Evan gershkovic is not a spy he is
a talented resourceful dedicated
professional journalist he doesn't
belong in jail it's not where he belongs
he belong in this Newsroom he's being
held hostage essentially and through no
fault of his own
he's Behind Bars
when Wall Street Journal reporter Evan
gershkovic was detained in Russia in
March and charged with Espionage he was
simply doing his job the journal his
colleagues and the Biden Administration
deny the allegation it's Auto rubbish
um Evan was doing what reporters do
they're detaining this Wall Street
Journal reporter let him go a 31 year
old american-born journalist with
Russian Heritage he has spent more than
five years covering Russia he joined the
journal last January a month before
Russia invaded Ukraine Evan is a an
editor's reporter it's the reporter that
you dream about we knew from the time he
joined us last year that we have a
winner I just remember this incredible
excitement about Russia he was telling
me about the books he was reading uh get
to to get to know the country better he
was incredibly excited about the
prospect of reporting from that he
believes that being on the ground is
really important and we all benefit from
that Evan's reporting took him across
the former Soviet Union including to the
Belarus Ukraine border where he was the
only American reporter who could see the
first wounded Russian forces being taken
home he profiled Russian dissidents and
Kremlin supporters alike and he traveled
Beyond Moscow to bring readers important
information contributing to wsj's
podcasts and videos along the way they
are worried uh extremely worried about
uh what I think everybody has seen as an
increasingly erratic government in
Moscow so I had the privilege of
interviewing Evan for a video about
Kazakhstan and first of all it was very
clear right off the bat that his
knowledge of the former Soviet Union was
extremely deep he knew it like the back
of his hand so when I was in Kazakhstan
I spoke with a lawmaker and he invoked
this Siberian fairy tale so The Story
Goes that a bear and the CH and this
chipmunk were friends one day this bear
was in a really good mood and it tries
to Pat the Chipmunk on the back
uh but it you know it still has claws
and it scratched the chipmunk and that's
why these Chipmunks or what Chipmunks
now have these three stripes on their
backs this par parliamentarian's point
was that you know
Kazakhstan will be friends with Russia
but it's still a bear and they need to
watch their backs colleagues who work
closely with Evan say he has a deep
affection for Russia and even felt
blessed to have accreditation from the
Kremlin to report there Evan always
spoke about his love for Russian culture
tradition literature and food that you
know as a person who is from a Russian
background he could actually be more
um more effective in telling the Roger
story there are not many people with the
talent and the language skills and the
knowledge of Russia record and the
documents to be able to go there and
work there who can do it as well as he
can and he he understood this he
understood the great privilege that he
has in covering this country I mean
everyone will tell you he's just a
really kind of uh fun person to to be
around I think that's one of the things
that makes him so good at his job
because he's someone that people kind of
enjoy being around must have been after
midnight you know the
and and everywhere was closed so we just
stood on the street talking about what
was happening about our experiences you
know from three generations perhaps of
Wall Street Journal or Russia coverage
just sharing
um what you know what we've seen how
things have changed how things were the
same
um and and that was that was that was a
special moment I remember without
reporting on the ground in Russia grew
more perilous as the war raged on and on
March 29th Evans fellow correspondents
knew something was wrong
after I hadn't heard from him before
seven hours I got worried shot on a
message it didn't go through
and then I reached out to our security
team the next morning Evan was seen
being escorted from court by Russian
officers he's facing a possible prison
sentence of up to 20 years it's the
first time Russia has brought a spy case
against an American reporter since the
Cold War on April 2nd Secretary of State
Anthony blinken called his Russian
counterpart to demand Evan's release I
can't even begin to imagine what what he
must be going through
but he's the he's he's I think he's he's
really strong
um mentally and physically so um you
know I hope you will um persevere Evan
is not the kind of guy who wants to be
the story everyone wants to tell
the story about Russia about what's
happening in Russia and I can't wait for
him to get out and start telling that
story again
[Music]